es geht es weiter mit dem nächsten
programmpunkt top 23 impulse für
einzelhandel und innenstädte ein antrag
der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
nachhaltigen kurse für einzelne und
innenstädte so heißt ja an zwei unteren
fordert die unions fraktion die
bundesregierung auf den einzelhandel und
die attraktivität der innenstädte mit
insgesamt 20 maßnahmen zu unterstützen
und
und carsten linnemann hat als erster
redner hier das wort
er ist erstellten fraktions vorsitzender
und stellvertreter im parteivorsitz und
kollegen meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren ich möchte mit einem zitat
einsteigen
auf architekturzeichnungen ist es immer
still in städten wie das hat mal vor
einiger zeit der niederländische
schriftsteller cees nooteboom gesagt
heute würde ihm denke ich mal dieses
zitat nicht mehr so leicht über die
lippen gehen auf architekturzeichnungen
ist es immer still im städten nie fakt
ist die innenstädte in deutschland
werden immer stiller wir haben viel
leerstand im ruhrgebiet gibt städte wo
jedes dritte ladenlokal
ruhig gestellt ist ein euro leben aber
auch ein euro shops aber auch handy
läden und vieles mehr prägen das
innenstadt leben zu sehen
ich komme selbst aus einem
einzelhandelsgeschäft meine eltern
hatten über 40 jahre eine buchhandlung
ich war damals lauf junge wie das so war
musste die botengänge erledigen in den
90er jahren die stadt war vielfältig die
stadt war kleinteilig es gab
qualifizierten
einzelhandel es gab eigentümergeführte
unternehmen und jede stadt jede
innenstadt war irgendwie anders aus
das hat sich heute geändert heute sieht
eben jede innenstadt gleich aus wir
verlieren jedes jahr tausende geschäfte
in diesem jahr die prognose
16.000 schließung in den deutschen
innenstädten vor allem der kleine
fachhandel ja wir erleben einen
strukturwandel die digitalisierung hat
den einzelhandel verändert und die
korona krise diese entwicklung nochmals
beschleunigt mein mann muss sich das auf
der zunge zergehen lassen im ersten jahr
2020 ist der onlinehandel um 20 25
prozent gestiegen auf 70 milliarden
jahresumsatz und ein jahr später
nochmals um 20 prozent auf 100
milliarden nicht dass sie mich falsch
verstehen die cdu/csu-fraktion will
diesen strukturwandel nicht aufhalten
ganz im gegenteil diejenigen
mittelständler in den innenstädten die
stationär sehr erfolgreich sind sind
auch in der regel online technisch sehr
erfolgreich nein uns geht es um einen
anderen punkt wir wollen mit diesem
antrag dagegen halten gegen die verödung
der innenstädte wir wollen die zukunft
der städte gewinnen wir wollen die
innenstädte als erlebnisraum schaffen
als begegnungsstätte als
kommunikationsplattform wo sich menschen
treffen wo sich menschen austauschen das
ist der kitt der unsere gesellschaft
zusammenhält
dieser antrag hat sehr viele punkte ich
schaffe das aus zeitgründen nicht auf
alle punkte einzugehen aber ich habe mir
mal erlaubt persönlich so die drei
punkte heraus zu ziehen die meines
erachtens im moment zentral sind der
erste punkt ist der kurzfristige im
stationären handel ist es so in
deutschland dass die frequenz immer noch
20 25 prozent in den innenstädten
unterhalb des krisen niveaus liegt jetzt
kommt die ukraine krise eine große
verunsicherung
der einzelhandel spricht davon dass wir
eine umsatz konnte im moment haben und
deshalb sind wir der meinung das beste
instrument das beste steuerliche
kurzfristige instrument um diesen
einzelhandel zu helfen ist die
verlustverrechnung dass hier
[Applaus]
der vergangenheit mit den verlusten von
heute verrechnen weil wir dann zielgenau
genau die unternehmen treffen die die
zukunft auf ihrer seite haben ja die
digitalisierung investieren wollen und
vieles mehr der zweite punkt städtebau
und stadtplanung der kollege ulrich
lange wird gleich auf dieses thema
eingehen aber lassen sie mich einsatz
dazu sagen die städte der zukunft werden
sich verändern wir werden mehr wohnraum
schaffen müssen in den innenstädten
übrigens auch mehr leben wir brauchen
auch mehr junge menschen wir sehen ja in
den städten wo junge menschen sind wo
universitäten teile ihrer universität in
die innenstädte legen wie beispielsweise
münster wie freiburg die bayreuther ist
leben in der bude aber auch das thema
sicherheit es kann nicht sein ich
spreche mal von meiner person ich habe
zwei drei jahren mal in frankfurt gelebt
ich habe wirklich auf der zeil meine
wohnung gehabt da war abends nichts mehr
los weil die leute nicht in die stadt
gegangen sind weil sie angst hatten weil
der no go areas waren genau dagegen
müssen wir halten übrigens wer das gut
macht ist der nordrhein-westfälische
innenminister er wird rollt der geht
dagegen vor auch das ist innenstadt
politische zukunft der dritte punkt bin
der meinung der einzelhandel brauchen
der aufmerksamkeit
ich beobachte mich selbst dabei ich
werde angesprochen damit gesagt herr
lindemann müssen wir über die
öffnungszeiten reden dann sage ich nee
das ist landespolitik dann geht es über
die erreichbarkeit dass kommunalpolitik
die landespolitiker sagen denn zum
städtele geben das ist bundespolitik
damit muss schluss sein wir müssen eine
plattform schaffen wo sich alle begegnen
alle an eine allianz für den innenstadt
für die innenstädte das land bund und
kommunen gemeinsam ganzheitlich dieses
thema betrachtet und nicht jeder immer
wie bei anderen themen auch die
verantwortung wegschieben und nicht
selber die verantwortung trage dafür
steht die cdu/csu und ist so
lassen sich zum schluss noch eine
persönliche anmerkung machen ich bin
hier spontan eingesprungen ich will mich
auch nicht mit fremden federn schmücken
dieser antrag ist maßgeblich verfasst
wurden von metzler jan metzler hat
corona wir wünschen ihnen alles gute
genesung herzliche grüße auch hier aus
dem deutschen bundestag in berlin
ich habe mich heute gerne vertreten weil
dieses thema auch für mich ein
herzensanliegen ist ich hab' skizziert
warum das der fall ist nicht nur für
mich als person sondern auch für die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion und ich würde
sie bitten diesen antrag nicht einfach
aus parteitaktischen gründen weg zu
schmettern sondern sich ernsthaft mit
diesem antrag in unseren argumenten
auseinanderzusetzen hetzerischen
carsten linnemann in der tat
stellvertretende parteivorsitzende der
cdu ist er seit dezember aber seit
dezember ist ja nicht mehr
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
so viel muss noch mal gesagt werden er
war ja lange jahre der vorsitzende der
mittelstandsvereinigung insofern war er
hier heute auch der richtige ersatz
redner für die cdu/csu der
mittelstandsbeauftragte der spd
esra limbacher hat jetzt das wort
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen diese
koalition ist eine die handelt und nicht
einfach nur redet oder papiere erstellt
diese koalition ist eine die felsenfest
hinter einem stabilen und
zukunftssicheren einzelhandel in unserem
land steht ein einzelhandel der nicht
nur eine wohnortnahe versorgung
gewährleistet sondern der einer der
wichtigsten faktoren für lebendige
innenstädte und ortszentren in unseren
gemeinden ist und liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der union ist grenzt schon
ein wenig so ein bisschen an 30 kite
hier in diesem hause heute wohlfeile
forderungen zur zukunft unserer
innenstädte zu erheben während das
zuständige innenministerium
16 jahre unionsgeführten und die diese
probleme verschlafen blockiert und
ignoriert hat diese probleme von heute
sind versäumnisse von gestern liebe
kolleginnen verwegen
deswegen ließen sich der antrag auch wie
einem schulbuch über das was sie in den
vergangenen jahren eben nicht geschafft
haben insofern sage ich danke schön für
diese auflistung sage ihnen aber auch
wir werden es besser machen
diese auflistung wäre allerdings
tatsächlich gar nicht nötig gewesen denn
das allermeiste findet sich schon längst
in unserem nicht nur wahlprogramm in
unserem koalitionsvertrag oder in der
innenstadt strategie von der cia
maßgeblich abgeschrieben haben in diesem
antrag copy & paste das kann jeder wir
bekennen uns zur innenstadt strategie
und führen diese form genauso wie das
förderprogramm zukunftsfähige städte und
zentren und genauso wie das programm
lebendige zentren im rahmen des bund
länder
städtebauförderung die zeiten und da
haben sie recht sind aber viel zu ernst
für einfache parteipolitik denn der
einzelhandel steckt tatsächlich seit
jahren in einer ernsten krise
vordergründig das stimmt sind die zahlen
tatsächlich gut wir sehen positive
umsatzentwicklung aber wenn man mal
rechts und links neben den
lebensmitteleinzelhandel short sehen wir
dass dem stationären vor allen dingen
monfort handel bei der bekleidung zum
beispiel -32
umsatzrückgang im vergleich zu 2009 10
bei den schuhen bei den schulen
verkäufen minus 35 prozent
umsatzrückgang bei den spielwaren und
sportartikel minus 15 prozent
umsatzrückgang das alles sind keine
guten zahlen und diese entwicklung des
einzelhandel ist doch eng verknüpft wie
mit den innenstädten und dorfzentren und
ortszentren in unseren gemeinden denn
dass die innenstädte veröden ist nicht
erst seit der korona krise ein problem
sondern wird doch spätestens seit dem
aufkommen des onlinehandels und dem
trend einkaufszentren auf der so
genannten grünen wiese zu bauen
beklagt in unserem land aber warum sind
uns die innenstädte und ortszentren in
unserem land so wichtig und warum ist
der einzelhandel uns einiges in der
beziehung so wichtig innenstädte und
zentren in unseren gemeinden sind echte
identifikation sword für die gesamte
bürgerschaft sie sind neben ihrer
wirtschaftlichen bedeutung vor allen
dingen doch soziale politische und
kulturelle
zentren unseres gemeinwesens sie sind
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
visitenkarten unserer städte und
gemeinden und deswegen lohnt sich jede
investition jede bemühung um sie zu
fördern und deswegen ist es richtig dass
diese koalition auf eine revitalisierung
der innenstädte und ortszentren
ernsthaft setzt und beim städtebau beim
wohnungsbau nicht halt macht liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
lassen sie mich was uns aber noch einen
wie ich finde ganz wichtigen punkt
machen der stationäre handel in
deutschland braucht attraktive
rahmenbedingungen und im strukturwandel
gegenüber dem reinen online handel
bestehen und von der digitalisierung
profitieren zu können es braucht
wirklich fairen wettbewerb zwischen
geschäftsmodellen
digitaler großunternehmen und den lokal
verwurzelten unternehmen und 1 geht
nicht das sage ich jetzt auch mal
einrichtungen der kolleginnen und
kollegen von der union weil sie das ja
schon jahrelang immer nicht so wahr
haben wollen es kann nicht sein dass
kleine anzahl einzelhandel händler mehr
steuern in deutschland zahlen als global
agierende versand konzerne damit muss
endlich schluss sein liebe kollegen
kollegen das ist ein gebot der fairness
und
deswegen sitzt auch unser stärkster
kämpfer für den einzelhandel im
kanzleramt dass olaf scholz der als
einziger in der bundesregierung vorne
weg gegangen ist um für die globale
mindeststeuer zu kämpfen die union war
nicht dabei olaf scholz hat es getan wo
waren sie
eins kann ich ihnen auch nicht ersparen
liefert kolleginnen und kollegen von der
union da haben sie nämlich mit dem
antrag den echten bock geschossen sie
reden und fabulieren den antrag in ihrem
antrag über autofreie innenstädte
abseits der frage wie sinnvoll das
tatsächlich ist da kann man darüber
diskutieren wir für den einzelhandel bis
zwei zitate von vor wenigen tagen hier
aus der hauptstadt-cdu vorlesen
wirtschaftspolitische sprecher christian
gräff von der cdu in berlin die
sogenannte flaniermeile meile mit rad
autobahn hat der friedrichstraße weit
mehr schafft geschadet als genutzt ihr
kollege oliver friederici
verkehrspolitischer sprecher der cdu
hier in berlin es sei ein geburtsfehler
gewesen die friedrichstraße nur aus
sicht des radverkehrs zu denken was soll
denn nun gelten frage ich mich entweder
ist es ihre position die darauf abzielt
offensichtlich neuerdings dass ihr rad
oder autofreie innenstädte sich wünschen
oder ist es eben die position der cdu
berlin die sind genau das gegenteil sagt
aber ich finde sie müssen sich mal
entscheiden was sie wirklich wollen das
passt alles nicht zusammen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
einzelhandel in deutschland und unsere
innenstädte stehen vor enormen und
vielfältigen herausforderungen diese
koalition handelt und packt diese
herausforderung an ich freue mich daher
bei diesem thema auf eine gute
zusammenarbeit vielen dank
[Applaus]
darf ich kurz den telefonierenden
kollegen aus der fdp-fraktion bitten
sollte das ein längeres gespräch werden
würden sie bitte den saal verlassen
danke
nächster redner für die fdp fraktion ist
jetzt klar
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin werte
kollegen und kollegen
liebe cdu fraktion hat sich ihren antrag
vor ein paar wochen in der planung
gesehen habe dachte ich mir so jahr
präsentiert sich heute der brandstifter
als feuerwehr und
ich kann ihnen sagen ich bin ein center
seit über 30 jahren ich weiß wovon ich
rede
und jemand wie ihre fraktionen die
gerade in den letzten beiden jahren also
massiv knüppel zwischen die beine der
einzelhändler hoffen hat und jetzt hier
öffentlichkeitswirksam auftritt und die
regierung auffordert gehhilfen zu
verteilen das finde ich schon ziemlich
absurd
und wenn ihnen der einzelhandel und die
innenstädte in den letzten jahren auch
nur einen pfifferling wert gewesen wäre
dann hätten sie die sinnlosen lockdown
zur zweijährigen
nicht mit beschlossen noch nicht
umgesetzt und es hat sich alles
angeführt für uns da draußen gegen
großes konjunkturprogramm für den online
handel
und ganz ehrlich als ich an ihren
auftritt denken wenn ich an ihren
auftritt denke am 16.12 letzten jahres
als wir hier in der aktuellen stunde
gefordert haben die 2g regeln für
einzelne abzuschaffen das war wirklich
ein deutliches zeichen wo sie stehen und
für wen sie stehen für den einzelhandel
die innenstädte jedenfalls nicht
und ich weiß sie halten diese ganzen
maßnahmen immer noch für gerechtfertigt
aber ich verrate ihnen mein geheimnis
die schweden
trotz keiner kroner maßnahmen trotz kein
zweig regeln die leben immer noch und
ich glaube es wird das so bleiben
und wenn ich ihnen noch ein beispiel
geben kann für ihre kompetenz in meinem
wahlkreis war im letzten jahr
wirtschaftsminister unterwegs und
versuchte meinen gegenkandidaten zu
unterstützen
ich würde ihm empfehlen sich war das
video an das war sehr sehr spektakulär
und der harald meyer hat uns versucht
anhand seiner magenta formenden
krawatten eine symbiose herzustellen
zwischen online und stationärem
einzelhandel also wenn sie meinen
wochenende 20 minuten zeit haben tun
sich das angehen so altmaier und töten
ein es ist glaube ich ein highlight auch
für sie
und 1 noch ihr antrag
das thema inflation
kam bei ihnen nicht wo haben sie das
nicht haben schon was er jetzt gerade
draußen passiert was das für
auswirkungen ich habe es nicht gelesen
aber wahrscheinlich ist das auch nicht
so wichtig und sie wissen es auch nicht
und dann noch eins
ich hätte mir gewünscht es käme von
ihnen eine zusicherung sie sind jetzt
eine position dass sie nie wieder bei 2g
sanktionen und bei lok bei uns mitmachen
und denn sie mitmachen dann vielleicht
wirklich dazu übergehen könnten den
händlern auch eine wirkliche erstattung
und nicht diese komischen
naja sie nennen es fördermittel also für
mich ist das häufig ganz üblen
mogelpackung und vielleicht ja
schadenersatz mal die richtige
richtung aber dazu sind sicherlich
bereit
und ich kann ihnen sagen da draußen im
einzelhandel ist im moment wirklich
katastrophal die umsätze sind deutlich
unter alkohol nie wo
die menschen draußen gehen nicht in die
städte die nutzen jetzt gerade den
sommer und fahren ein bisschen urlaub
und ich kann das auch verstehen weil es
ja nicht wissen was im herbst ja noch
alles passiert
und liebe kollegen von der cdu durch so
ich möchte sie auffordert wenn sie mal
wirklich mal für einzelne tun möchten
neben sie regelmäßig 1000 euro in die
hand gehen in ihrer innenstädte und
geben dass bei ihren einzeln aus das ist
was das können sie sofort tun und da
würden sich auch alle in ihren regionen
darüber freuen und
das ganze hier betrifft natürlich auch
die fraktion ja auf der linken seite
dummerweise landet dann wahrscheinlich
alles kontext ihr text discounter und
ich wünsche ihnen ein schönes wochenende
vielen dank
der bundestag debattiert immer ein
antrag der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
impulse für einzelhandel und
innenstädte und mike außendorf von
bündnis 90 die grünen hat jetzt das wort
er ist mitglied im wirtschaftsausschuss
sehr geehrte präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen der antrag der union und ich
danke ihnen dafür dass sie das thema
heute ausgebracht haben das ist ein sehr
wichtiges thema ist der hat ja wirklich
interessante anknüpfungspunkte und
insbesondere in der analyse gibt es
große übereinstimmung zur bedeutung der
innenstädte schreiben sich zitiert erst
mal wörtlich weil es wirklich gut
zusammengefasst ist innenstädte mit
einer anziehenden funktionsvielfalt sind
mehr als nur einkaufsstraßen lebendige
und vielfältige innenstädte sind
kulturelles erbe und als ort der
begegnung des zusammenkommens und der
gemeinschaft unverzichtbar für unser
zusammenleben und den standort
deutschland
gleichzeitig sind sie ohne florierenden
und funktionierenden einzelhandel
undenkbar sollte um richtig vollkommene
übereinstimmung und auch der zitierte
handelsverband hat mit seiner
einschätzung einer existenzbedrohenden
lage für viele geschäfte vollkommen
recht auch da geben sie die haltung des
hde sagt passend wieder richtet ihr das
nochmal die wiederkehrenden lockt downs
und die damit verbundene verunsicherung
der kunden hätten den einzelhandel so
hart getroffen wie kaum eine andere
branche das herunterfahren des
öffentlichen lebens mit der weitgehenden
monatelange schließung der geschäfte hat
viele handelsunternehmen
unverschuldet in not gebracht
eigenkapital und kreditmöglichkeiten
sind oftmals ausgeschöpft so weit der
chor doch das was die korona pandemie
jetzt verschärft und beschleunigt hat
das ist doch eine jahrelange entwicklung
und da haben wir immer wieder darauf
hingewiesen und jetzt schreiben sie in
ihrem antrag wir müssen umdenken und das
ist nach 16 jahren regierungszeit etwas
spät und jetzt kommen sie hier mit einem
notizzettel voller in denen so ähnlich
wie gestern beim entlastungsgesetz mein
kollege felix donnerstag hat das da
zusammengefasst das klingt so ein
bisschen wie nach dem super hits der
80er und 90er jahre aber einmal handy
haben als opposition mit diesem antrag
schon ein stand an der stelle
hinzugelernt in der vergangenheit haben
sie immer versäumt auf die finanzierung
einzugehen das habe sich aufgenommen und
immerhin
die bedeutung die erfasst aber sie
schreiben dann das soll sich im rahmen
der zur verfügung stehenden
haushaltsmittel bewegen das was sie mit
ihren 20 punkten fordern also bitte dann
müssen sie auch den nächsten schritt
gehen und sagen wo dann an anderer
stelle eingespart werden soll und noch
ein einsatz zu ihrem gang in die
opposition in den ersten wochen haben
sie ja versucht ihre versäumnisse uns
als ampel anzukreiden jetzt machen sie
neuen schritt sie haben gute ideen ihrer
vorgänger opposition zusammengefasst als
prüfauftrag eingebracht und oben drüber
geschrieben wir denken um also das ist
mal ein interessanter move ich bin
gespannt was da noch so kann ich
in der letzten wahlperiode haben wir als
grüne mit drucksache 19 23 11 6 zum
beispiel ein gesetzentwurf eingebracht
zur verbesserung der situation von
kleinen gewerbemieter erinnern da geht
es um ein verlängerungs recht besseres
kündigungsschutz hätten sie damals
einfach so durchwinken können dann wäre
heute vieles einfacher für die
einzelhändlerin in den straßen
wir haben ich komme jetzt dazu was wir
umgesetzt haben schon als koalition habe
die haben schon reagiert
wir haben ja schon reagiert und die
mittel des im letzten in der letzten wp
angestoßenen programms zukunftsfähige
innenstädte und zentren mehr als
verzehnfacht auf nun 250 millionen euro
das ist das was diese koalition bereits
auf den weg gebracht hat außerdem haben
wir die überbrückungshilfe 4 als
zentrales kroner hilfsinstrument bis
juli 2022 verlängert ergänzen das durch
kredite garantien und bürgschaften und
das ist auch eine erleichterung ganz
wesentlich für die händlerinnen in den
innenstädten
auch für digitalisierungs gerissen und
kleinbetriebe und geschäfte sind mittel
im haushalt eingestellt digitalisierung
sprechen sie auch an 25 millionen euro
für das programm go digital alleine
jetzt möchte ich aber noch einen punkt
konkret eingehen dann hat mein vorredner
von der spd aufgegriffen da verlässt er
mich dann doch der mut sie schreiben
einer sie wollen prüfen inwieweit das
konzept autofreie innenstädte und
gebührenpflichtiger parkplatz jetzt zur
belebung und steigerung der
aufenthaltsqualität beiträgt aber sie
schreiben gleich eine muss aber auch
gucken und das die besucherfrequenz sich
darunter leidet leidet und die bedeutung
des autos schmälert und da kommt ihr die
alte auto partei cdu hindurch unter
linnemann sie haben ja eben freiburg und
münster als positivbeispiele angeführt
und ausgerechnet da haben wir viel
lebensraum umgewandelt viel straßenraum
in lebensraum umgewandelt und da für sie
besonders viele rad fahren und das wäre
der richtige weg
übrigens auch die metastudie dass das
difu mit dem fahrrad zum einkaufen
stellt fest in internationalen
vergleichen überall dort wo ich mehr
radfahren in die einkaufsstraßen bekomme
steigen die umsätze des einzelhandels
und das ist ein ganz zentraler punkt um
die innenstädte zu beleben
es gibt viele weitere beispiele aus new
york aus wien aus hamburg barcelona sie
können sich überall umgucken bei der
umsetzung der maßnahmen sind die
kommunen vielfach weiter als wir hier
auf bundesebene da können wir das
natürlich gerne unterstützen ich dann
mal beispiele in meiner heimatstadt
danke stadtbach wurde 2020 schon
beschlossen parteiübergreifend damals
auch in meiner stimme im stadtrat die
sondernutzungsgebühren für
außengastronomie und geschäfte
auszusetzen damit sie eben den platz
draußen nutzen können das wird vielfach
genutzt und das ist ganz und gar gratis
schnelle hilfe da sind die kommunen weit
war schon wirklich sehr weit und das
sollten auch weil unterstützen
ich komme zum schluss sie sehen also
kommunen in deutschland und weltweit
sind weiter die koalition hat bereits
gehandelt und wir werden die ziele von
klimagerechten menschenfreundlichen in
städten mit hoher aufenthaltsqualität
und besseren bedingungen für den handel
weiter verfolgen banken
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die fraktion die
linke pascal leyser
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren in der tat sieht sich
der einzelhandel schon seit jahren
vielfältigen veränderungen ausgesetzt
die massive negative folgen für die
beschäftigten kleine händler und die
innenstädte haben deshalb ist es gut
dass sie von der union dieses thema
heute auf die tagesordnung gebracht
haben und die antrag beinhalte dabei
durchaus auch aus unserer sicht
diskussionswürdige vorschläge hat aber
auch große lehrstellen
und auf einige von dem muss ich an
dieser stelle natürlich eingehen
zunächst sie schreiben selbst das ist
die krone pandemie war die das laden
stahlhandel zuletzt massiv beschleunigt
hat aber darüber welche mitverantwortung
sie dafür tragen darüber schweigen sie
sich geflissentlich aus es waren doch
sie vorneweg als wirtschaftsminister die
in der großen koalition nicht in der
lage waren hilfsprogramm aufzulegen
tatsächlich einen umfassenden schutz von
kleinen einzelnen der pandemie bieten
eine kritik übrigens auch von dem von
ihnen ansonsten immer gern zitierten 1
handelsverband hde immer wieder zurecht
formuliert wurde bis zuletzt muss sie
nichts daran geändert dass ein
unternehmen einen umsatzausfall von
mindestens 30 prozent verzeichnen musste
um überhaupt unterstützung zu halten mit
leider haben auch herr habe und die
ampel koalition daran zuletzt nichts
mehr geändert dabei wissen wir doch alle
dass gerade kleine einzelhändler die
unverschuldet von umsatzeinbußen von 20
bis 25 prozent betroffen sind dies nicht
auf dauer verkraften können und viel
lieber ihr geschäft aufgeben bevor sie
in die insolvenz gezwungen werden da
würde ich mir schon ein bisschen mehr
selbstkritik erwünscht
zweitens als linke begrüßte es
ausdrücklich wenn die kommunen gestärkt
werden wenn es um die
eingriffsmöglichkeiten für die stadt-
und raumplanung geht also was wo gebaut
und wofür genutzt werden darf das gilt
liebe kollegin kollegen von der union
ausdrücklich auch für ihre forderungen
des einkaufs gebiete auf der grünen
wiese zu ungunsten der orts und
stadtkerne von den kommunen auch wieder
leichter rückabgewickelt werden können
warum sie allerdings nicht schon
gehandelt haben als sie noch die
regierung gestellt haben würde mich
schon interessieren oder war es etwa die
spd die blockiert hat das müssen sie
schon mal untereinander nochmal klären
und hier auch vielleicht für alle
aufklären aber hier braucht es mehr mut
und da ist natürlich jetzt die neue
bundesregierung gefordert wenn wir
wollen dass dauerhaft leer stehende
geschäfts und büroräume sinnvoll genutzt
werden können dann braucht es auch hier
stärkere eingriffsmöglichkeiten der
kommunen um auch spekulativen leerstand
denen gibt es auch beenden zu können und
auch um genauere vorgaben im interesse
der kommunen machen zu können für die
nutzung von werbeflächen um bonus
strukturen zu verhindern leben politik
und
drittens das ladensterben hat es wie die
union im antrag richtig schreibt sehr
unterschiedliche gründe und auch
regional lokal ist das sehr stark zu
differenzieren auf vieles gehen sie auch
im antrag ein aber worüber sie kein wort
verlieren das ist die situation in
überhitzten immobilienmärkten in berlin
münchen oder frankfurt wo die
explodierenden gewerbemieten für viele
kleine gewerbetreibende dazu führen dass
diese um ihre existenz bangen müssen und
auch maßgeblich dort zum ladensterben
kleiner gewerbetreibender
beigetragen haben dass die darüber kein
wort verlieren und die
immobilienwirtschaft an dieser stelle
nicht kritisieren das ist bezeichnet
als linke haben wir dazu in der
vergangenen legislatur als erste
fraktion konkrete vorschläge vorgelegt
vorgelegt in angespannten grabe
mietmärkten brauchen wir endlich eine
mietpreis bremse für gewerbemieten oder
einen anspruch für gewerbemieter auf
mindestvertragslaufzeit und
der außenluft sie haben das ja auch
angesprochen die grünen haben ja
ähnliche vorschläge gemacht sie haben
jetzt die union kritisiert dass sie das
in der letzten legislatur nicht gemacht
haben ich erwarte dass die ampel
koalition jetzt dafür sorgt dass auch
die kleinen gewerbemieter heftig
geschützt werden da will ich mal klares
bekenntnis zum koalitionsvertrag findet
sich dazu zumindest ja nichts ich hoffe
da kommt noch was
eine weitere große leerstelle im antrag
liebe kollegen von der union ist die
perspektive der beschäftigten außer
einer ausweitung der ladenöffnungszeiten
haben sie für diese nichts zu bieten ich
finde das bezeichnend dass sie für
diejenigen die wir alle als heldinnen
und helden des alltags in der wanne
mehere gewertschätzt haben nichts
anderes als längere aber es hat riesen
ich komme zum schluss was wir
tatsächlich brauchen sind einheitliche
wettbewerbsbedingungen einheitliche
löhne in diesem bereich deswegen muss
dafür gesorgt werden dass endlich wieder
die tarifverträge für den einzelhandel
allgemeinverbindlich erklärt werden
können für den stationären die für den
online handel bei amazon und co vielen
dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
was bleiben meiser war das für die linke
impulse für einzelhandel und innenstädte
der antrag der cdu csu wird hier beraten
und manfred todenhausen von der fdp ist
der nächste redner er ist der
handwerks politische sprecher seiner
fraktion an die inflation und jetzt vor
allem die sorgen um die ukraine krise
die wir haben die stimmung der
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher schon
lange auf eine harte probe gestellt noch
mehr wurde der stationäre einzelhandel
belastet am anfang dürfen wir wegen der
lok downs nicht einkaufen gehen dann
haben die masken pflicht und die kontakt
beschränkungen viele menschen vor
einkaufen abgehalten und nun treiben die
preissteigerungen die ängste auch wenn
geld zum konsum sogar vorhanden ist aber
im frühjahr und im frühjahr die in der
regel eigentlich die lust und am
einkaufen steigt findet das derzeit noch
nicht so stadt meine damen und herren
wie sehr hätte ich mir von der cdu
diesen antrag früher gewünscht wie sehr
hätte ich mir diesen antrag in den
letzten zwei jahren gewünscht
als die pandemie dem einzelhandel
deutlich zugesetzt hat da fand nicht
dazu haben sie haben nicht nur keinen
eigenen antrag gestellt sondern unsere
fdp vorschläge die in die gleiche
richtung gingen ausdrücklich abgelehnt
und wir haben als bei den demokraten
direkt nach der bundeswahl gezeigt wie
man sich wirklich für den einzelhandel
einsetzt wir waren es wir waren es die
dafür gesorgt haben dass der
einzelhandel im weihnachtsgeschäft 20 21
offen bleiben durfte dadurch konnte die
geschäfte endlich mal wieder geld
verdienen und hatten die möglichkeit
viele kunden zu bekommen sie als union
haben gegen diese öffnungen gestimmt
viele von ihnen haben stattdessen wieder
mit einem lockdown bedroht gerade
hendrik wüst den ich eigentlich sehr
schätze als vorsitzender der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
war ja ein ganz besonders scharfer
verfechter strengerer maßnahmen gut dass
er sich nicht durchsetzen konnte so
sahen wir endlich wieder offene
geschäfte
face restaurants und denn das schöne ist
wer einkaufen geht hat auch zeit zur
pause hat auch zeit für gastronomie denn
die gehören eng zusammen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen fakt ist leider
aktuell aber auch die
verbraucherstimmung ist noch sehr
zurückhaltend auch wenn die menschen
nach aufregung der korona bestimmungen
erstmals seit zwei jahren wieder mehr
freiheit zum einkaufen haben jetzt kommt
die union mit ihrem antrag und ihren 20
forderungen die wir sehr wohl zur
kenntnis genommen haben aber nicht weil
ihre ideen neuwaren nein sondern war
alleine unsere fraktionen in den letzten
wahlperiode als sie den
wirtschaftsminister gestellt haben drei
anträge hierzu vorgelegt haben und was
war ihre reaktion peter altmaier gefiel
sich mehr darin neue corona hilfen für
den geschlossenen einzelhandel zu
beschließen stadt die geschäfte mit
ihren tatsächlich funktionierenden
hygiene und abstands konzepten offen zu
halten und wir haben nicht nur damals
für den einzelhandel unsere stimmung
stimme erhoben sondern wir haben eben
unsere unterstützung auch in dem
koalitionsvertrag
zugesagt und arbeiten gemeinsam in der
koalition an der umsetzung die
herausforderungen der zukunft
dekarbonisierung und klimawende
demokratischer wandel und
fachkräftemangel sowie digitalisierung
verändertes konsumverhalten verhalten
das spürt natürlich auch der
einzelhandel da brauchen wir derzeit
nicht nur die förderung des
einzelhandels als solches sondern eben
langfristige strategien wie sie in den
beiden entlastungspaket die vorgebracht
werden und bei der abschaffung der eeg
umlage zum tragen kommen um gegen die
kalte progression kann ich ihnen sagen
hat der bundesfinanzminister maßnahmen
angekündigt die noch dieses jahr kommen
wir also auch da sind wir auf dem
richtigen weg unser finanzminister hat
die sorgen der bürgerinnen und bürger
der verbraucher auf dem schirm er packt
das an was nötig ist und was möglich ist
meine damen und herren mit der
initiative mit vielen initiativen wird
die bundesregierung auch zusammen mit
den ländern wie etwa nordrhein-westfalen
als gute beispiel mit seinem programm
digital coaches den einzelhandel lokal
und digital zukunftsfit machen da bitte
dazu gehört auch die förderung von
digitalisierung schnell im internet für
mehr hybride vertriebswege sie hatten
gerade angesprochen das ist der weg der
zukunft denn gerade fachgeschäfte also
kleine und mittlere betriebe des
stationären heimischen einzelhandel
müssen in zeiten nach corona im
wettbewerb mit dem handel auf großen
digitalen einkaufsplattform mithalten
können der wettbewerb ist da sehr
starken für mich persönlich gehört dann
allerdings lieber
koalitionspartner es ist meine
persönliche meinung gehört dann
irgendwann auch die lockerung bei den
öffnungszeiten an sonn und feiertagen
dazu die ladengeschäfte und nehmen
entsprechende gastronomie würde dadurch
erheblich gestärkt gestärkt wir wünschen
ich hier wünsche ich mir übrigens mehr
bewegung auch von den
wirtschaftspolitikern der union peter
altmaier
redete viel darüber aber er handelte
nicht das war eine verpasste chance aber
schauen wir nach vorne bei uns bei der
ampel koalition sich die zum
einzelhandel in den busch in guten
händen nein er ist in den besten händen
vielen dank
der nächste redner in der debatte 20 20
maßnahmen schlägt die cdu csu in ihrem
antrag impulse für den einzelhandel in
den innenstädten vor und ulrich lange
der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende in dem falls sie
ist abgeordneter hat jetzt 20 kollegen
zunächst freut es uns dass diese debatte
zur prominente zeit auch von allen
fraktionen entsprechend als notwendig
gewürdigt wird denn natürlich war die
korona pandemie noch mal eine große und
starke belastung für unseren
einzelhandel und wir sehen alle die
verwerfungen in unseren innenstädten
auf der anderen seite und das erlaube
ich mir auch an all die kritiker zu
sagen möchte ich zunächst im
einzelhandel danken und zwar jedem
einzelhändler der während corona für
sicheres einkaufen gesorgt hat mit
masken mit tests mit den regelungen ja
wir wollten gesundheit schützen und
einkaufen gehen das war unser ansatz
breit getragen und der war richtig
dankeschön an den einzelhandel an dieser
stelle
und dann liebe kollegen immer das ist
zwar ganz lustig mit dem 16 jahre nur
sie waren zwölf dabei gewann 12 dabei
und acht jahre für den bau zuständig für
den ich hier rede also ich wäre an ihrer
stelle da einfach etwas vorsichtiger
sonst müsste man permanent in der
historie von zwölf jahren arbeiten das
bringt nicht lassen sich meine lieben
kolleginnen und kollegen carsten
linnemann hat sehr eindrucksvoll
persönliche
erlebnisse und das befreiende zahlen
schon da geboten das will ich nicht
wiederholen aber die pandemie war
natürlich ein cut die sator sie war ein
brandbeschleuniger für all das was wir
in unseren städten sehen und zwar sowohl
in den ganz großen metropolen aber ganz
hinunter bis in die kleinen städte mit
5000 einwohnern die marktgemeinden wo
wir früher
florierende marktplätze hatten mit
geschäften rundrum wo wir jetzt ein euro
shops nagel shops oder gar nichts mehr
sehen und genau das ist das was uns
sorge macht und genau hier haben wir und
auch das ist nicht neu in den letzten
jahren immer wieder vorschläge
eingebracht und deswegen auch heute
wollen wir diese
konsequente arbeit mit und für den
einzelhandel fortsetzen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
der einzelhandel hat aber auch in den
letzten jahren wären corona bewiesen
dass er zu neuen geschäftsideen fähig
ist hat neue konzepte ausprobiert und
einiges hat auch ganz gut funktioniert
und jetzt liegt haben uns als politik
insgesamt und zwar über alle ebenen den
einzelhandel funktioniert ja nicht nur
von berlin aus oder über die
landesregierung sondern ein bisschen die
kommunalpolitik und deswegen ist ein
stringenter antrag und auftrag an die
politik insgesamt nicht zuviel
vorzuschreiben sondern vor ort in den
jeweiligen strukturen das zuzulassen was
man im rahmen der kommunalen
selbstverwaltung als notwendig erachtet
geht
steht da das baugesetz geht darum die
baunutzungsverordnung desto schwieriger
für den einzelhandel vor ort und das ist
genau unsere aufgabe im großen rahmen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
programm zukunftsfähige innenstädte und
zentren wurde angestoßen aus dem
innenministerium und dem bauministerium
heraus wir haben zusammen erkenntnis
defiziten in der letzten periode hatten
wir ja lieber kollege daldrup schon den
beirat innenstädte der seine arbeit
aufgenommen hat und viele ideen
geliefert hat es ist also kein
erkenntnis- defizit jetzt muss man
handeln und genau das will unser antrag
impuls zum handeln für unsere
innenstädte liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und lieber kollege außen doch da ist es
auch kein widerspruch zu sagen es gibt
auto freiheit und es gibt auf der
anderen seite erreichbarkeit wenn sie
kleine städte im ländlichen raum haben
brauchen sie erreichbarkeit mit dem auto
da ist der pnv einem eher
auf der anderen seite müssen sie wissen
wo sie quartiere und plätze schaffen die
autofreie erlebniszoo nnen sind zum
einkauf zum flanieren zum bleiben und
ihre beispiele wien barcelona hamburg
die passen jetzt nicht bei mir zur
donauwörth oettingen oder die linien an
der donau das ist anders und dann könnte
jeder kollege seine städte genau so
nenne ich
würde einfach mal einen persönlichen rat
geben statt der bio gemüse kiste mit dem
diesel transport vor der tür auf dem
wochenmarkt gehen regional einkaufen das
was es jetzt gibt frischen spargel
frische erdbeeren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir sind am wochenende im
wahlkreis es kann doch jeder tun und
dann auch noch mal bei seinen
bekleidungshändler vorbei das ist einzel
haben sie das ist regionalität das ist
lebensqualität tun wir es doch alle wir
stärken damit gemeinschaft und
einzelhandel
die baunutzungsverordnung das baugesetz
habe ich angesprochen die
städtebauförderung auf
städtebauförderung bringt leuchttürme in
die stadt deswegen liebe neue regierung
für die nationalen projekte des
städtebaus keine frischen mittel
einzustellen ist der erste fehler für
und die innenstädte und gegen die
entwicklung in unseren städten
korrigieren wieder zu weisen und dritten
lesung wir haben einen antrag vorgelegt
viele ideen wir freuen uns auf die
diskussion sie ist es allemal wert
dankeschön
franziska mushak spd fraktions die
nächste rednerin der debatte
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
geehrte damen und herren mehr kunst mehr
kultur mehr soziales in die innenstädte
ganz ehrlich großartig mein herz geht
auf wissen sie ich komme aus der
kreativwirtschaft und aus der sozialen
arbeit da ging es mir fiel um die
entwicklung von ortszentren mit
jugendarbeit gemeinschaftliches leben
kunst und kultur und besonders
demokratisches mitwirken
die einleitung ihres antrags und mein
bisheriger beruf haben also eins
gemeinsam wie sie es schon gesagt haben
endlich leben in die bude bringt
großartig
doch die vorschläge sind bekannt sie
werden schon seit sehr langer zeit von
der progressiven zivilgesellschaft
angebracht aber wo war die union in den
letzten 16 jahren um diese punkte
aufzugreifen städte in denen das
wirklich gut gelingt sind progressiv
regiert erfurt magdeburg
mannheim die liste könnte weitergehen
so hohe gewerbe mieten und
immobilienpreise verhindern dass mit
kultur und sozialen orten endlich leben
in die innenstädte kommt dass eine kita
sich ansiedeln kann das mehr
generationen heute entstehen oder das
mal kleine räume für kunst oder modernes
arbeiten bieten kann leider lassen sie
den punkt gewerbemieten im antrag völlig
unbekannt und wieder stellt sich mir die
frage wo war die union in den letzten 16
jahren wenn es um die regulieren und
regulierung von gewerbemieten ging und
wo ist die union heute wenn es darum
geht kultur kreativ und sozial
wirtschaft zu unterstützen
gleichzeitig schreiben sie dass
öffnungszeiten aufgeweicht werden und
mehr verkaufsoffene sonntage möglich
sein sollen wenn jemand tatsächlich bei
mir in der kleinen stadt dieses passende
personal dafür finden würde müsste es ja
auch anständig bezahlt werden das können
sich nur die großen handelsketten
leisten und die gibt es schon zu genüge
in unseren großstädten unseren kleinen
städten hilft das überhaupt nicht dabei
müsste das angebot unserer innenstädte
doch viel bunter und vielfältiger werden
vielmehr würde es die arbeitsbedingungen
im handel noch einmal verschärfen und
verschlechtern und die berufe noch
unattraktiver für junge menschen machen
sie glauben doch nicht dass ich durch
längere öffnungszeiten auch nur ein
prozent vom online-handel wieder zurück
verlagert das haben sie ihr selbst in
ihrem antrag so beschrieben dass es ein
zurück nicht geben wird und jetzt
versuchen sie es irgendwie doch aber ich
finde etwas hilflos sie schreiben dass
die kommunen die digitalisierung
voranbringen sollen ich finde diese
forderung recht frech wenn ich die
schwierige personallage und die
finanzielle situation zum beispiel
meiner stadt anschauen wie sollen denn
gerade ländliche regionen das alleine
leisten bevor sie von den kommunen die
digitalisierung verschiedener
lebensbereiche einfordern brauchen diese
doch erst einmal eine stabile und
schnelle internet für sendung und dann
auch das qualifizierte personal und wo
war die union in den letzten 16 jahren
wenn es um den ausbau des breitbands
ging ich fürchte sie haben noch jedes
aus ihrer vorherigen regierungszeit
aufzuarbeiten und vor allem empfehle ich
ihnen ihren werten parteikollegen in
sachsen mal von ihren großartigen ideen
zu erzählen die erlebe ich nämlich auf
kommunaler und auf landesebene ganz
anders
ehrlicherweise
hatte ich noch nie den eindruck dass der
union städte besonders wichtig sind
abgesehen von ihrem wert als
wirtschaftsstandort dass man dort gut
und gerne und bezahlbar leben kann
irgendwie nebensache hauptsache die
wirtschaft sieht sich an der rest der
wittern schon aber sehen sie so
umfunktioniert dass nicht das können sie
überall beobachten erst kommen die
kreativen werten die quartiere auf dann
siedeln sich geschäfte an und dann
profitiert davon die wirtschaft sie
schreiben dass die unionsgeführte
bundesregierung das bonusprogramm
zukunftsfähige innenstädte und zentren
angestoßen habe sie vergessen dabei und
das wurde heute auch schon gesagt dass
um ganz sicher nicht mit böser absicht
dass dabei erst mal 25 millionen euro
von ihnen zur verfügung gestellt wurden
und dann die spd mit dem damaligen
bundesfinanzminister olaf scholz den
beitrags- verzehnfacht hat
jetzt stellen sie forderungen an unsere
krones ministerin klara geywitz dabei
ist sie doch schon längst dran mit dem
beirat innenstädte traf sich anfangen
2022 sie können gerne zuhören mit den
kommunen wird die ministerin sich im
juli 22 zu diesem thema austauschen und
die innenstadt strategie wird ständig
weiterentwickelt sie sehen ihr antrag
ist noch nicht ganz ausgereift deshalb
lade ich sie ein lassen sie uns
gemeinsam die zukunft der innenstädte
gestalten lassen sie uns gemeinsam die
voraussetzungen schaffen dass menschen
mit dem bus mit dem fahrrad oder der
bahn in die innenstädte kommen
lassen sie uns daran arbeiten kleinere
innenstädte interessanter und
lebenswerter zu machen ich bin gespannt
auf die debatten in den ausschüssen
vielen dank und ein herzliches glückauf
franziska matschig war das für die spd
die union hat den antrag vorgelegt
impulse für einzelhandel und innenstädte
und fordert unter anderem
in abstimmung mit den bundesländern
solle geprüft werden ob eine
anlassbezogene ausweitung von den
ladenöffnungszeiten deutliche impulse
für den innerstädtischen einzelhandel
setzen können für die afg enrico kommen
immer
wieder stehen wir heute hier wieder
diskutieren wir über einen ihrer anträge
bei denen man sich fragen muss warum sie
das nicht schon in ihrer regierungszeit
die letzten 16 jahre gemacht haben ja
ich weiß sie können es nicht mehr hören
aber sie werden sich immer wieder
anhören müssen
gestern habe ich ihnen schon
habe ich ihnen schon gesagt herr spahn
hat gestern erwidert es habe ja an der
spd gelegen umso lustiger ist es heute
dass die spd ihnen dieselben vorhalte
macht die sie der spd machen ja da frage
ich mich wer hat ihn zusammen reagierte
altmaier im cdu ministerium herr scholz
das finanzministerium jetzt schieben sie
sich gegenseitig den schwarzen peter zu
ich glaube die politik die sie beide
zusammen zu verantworten haben was
schlechte politik und das muss sie heute
mal deutlich ausgesprochen werden
und wenn sie liebe cdu tatsächlich
vernünftige politik machen wollen und
die antrag von gestern und auch der
antrag von heute die sind ja im grunde
genommen gar nicht schlecht dann frage
ich mich warum geben sie dann immer
wieder hin zum politisch linken spektrum
warum warum schauen sie denn nicht mal
auf die marktwirtschaftliche seite denn
das was sie heute fordern der linnemann
verlustverrechnung sie haben es
angesprochen
das haben wir die gesamte letzte
legislatur gefordert also orientieren
sie sich lieber zum
marktliberalen zu marktwirtschaftlichen
spektrum hier im bundestag und nicht
immer nach links aber
kurz auch vielleicht noch zum antrag ich
habe leider nur drei minuten in dem ziel
was dieser was dieser antrag verfolgt
sind wir uns einig der stationäre
einzelhandel ist natürlich mehr als
handel weil er eben die innenstädte auch
gesellschaftlich und kulturell prägt das
besondere interesse an einem
florierenden einzelhandel ist also
tatsächlich mehr als wirtschaftspolitik
der dramatische verlust an markt teilen
gegenüber dem online handels aber zu
einem großen teil geben auch hausgemacht
geben durch die eben angesprochene
politik die steuerliche benachteiligung
schreit doch zum himmel amazon zahlt in
deutschland keinen cent steuern wie kann
das sein wie kann es sein dass gegenüber
einem kleinen fachgeschäft betreiber in
deutschland ohne steuerberater faktisch
derjenige nicht existieren kann amazon
liebe kollegen ist doch nicht gestern
erst vom himmel gefallen und auch ihre
forderungen nach einem bürokratischen
beratungs moratorium mod mutet schon
fast komisch an waren es doch die
regierungen unter unionsführung die
milliarden euro zusätzliche
bürokratiekosten dem handel in dem
letzten jahrzehnt aufgebürdet haben der
online-handel will und soll nicht wieder
sterben für viele menschen gerade im
ländlichen raum ist er eben die rettung
der stationäre handel muss nur die
gleichen chancen bekommen und gute
unternehmerische rdg ideen dazu gibt es
genug vielen dank
caroline orte bündnis 90 die grünen 10
ist rednerin in der debatte
[Applaus]
vergab präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen gute
lebensverhältnisse in unseren städten
das heißt mit menschen an schönen orten
zusammen kommen und gut versorgt zu sein
mit den dingen des alltäglichen lebens
attraktive und lebenswerte innenstädte
sind der ort an dem gute kommunale
gemeinschaft leben wohnen und arbeiten
möglich ist
doch so wichtig innenstädte für
gemeinschaft vor ort sind aktuell
verändern sie sich vielerorts rapide
denn discount rennt rasant steigende
immobilienpreise durch die pandemie
nochmals zunehmende online handel sind
die wesentlichen treiber
leerstände und verfallene infrastruktur
prägen zu oft unsere kleinen städte aber
auch die quartiere in den größeren
städten
in diesem punkt die union haben sie
recht und sie müssen einräumen dass
veränderungen dringend notwendig ist
aber bitte nicht mit den alten plänen
und rezepten von vorgestern das leben in
unseren städten von heute das braucht
ideen und konzepte für integrierte und
nachhaltige stadtentwicklung
mit der förderung des traditionellen
einzelhandels ist es nicht mehr getan
wer dafür sorgen will dass auch in
zukunft autos den platz in unseren
interessen und jedes gefühl von lebens
lebensqualität wortwörtlich im keim
ersticken der ist im letzten jahrhundert
hängen geblieben die innenstadt mit
zukunft die braucht eine
verkehrsentlastung des klimaneutrale
mobilität die autogerechte stadt die
hilft auch nicht im ländlichen raum
eine stärkere mischnutzung und kleinere
läden das ist in stadt der zukunft die
innenstadt mit zukunft sorgt dafür dass
menschen
mehr vorfinden als nur die möglichkeit
zu konsumieren wir brauchen plätze für
alle mit freiräumen für kinder und
jugendliche mit platz für
bürgerschaftliches engagement mit platz
für erholung und begegnung und liebe
union ja ein stück weit beschreiben sie
diese punkte in ihrem antrag es klingt
auch durch das die von diesem konzept
nicht einmal gehört haben freut mich es
stellt sich nur die frage warum und es
wurde heute schon öffentlich oft
angesprochen und ich frage mich trotzdem
entsprechende änderungen beispielsweise
der städtebauförderung in den letzten 16
jahren von ihrer fraktion entweder
verbaselt oder vehement blockiert wurden
in ihrem antrag fordert zum beispiel die
förderung von grünflächen und
zusätzliche klimaschutz und
anpassungsmaßnahmen
dass der klimawandel in form von
hitzewellen und überschwemmungen auch
unsere innenstädte betrifft das ist
keine ganz neue erkenntnis
klimaschutz steigert lebensqualität in
unseren städten mit klimaanpassung
schützen wir sensible gruppen und
kritische infrastruktur liebe union es
ist unglaubwürdig
glaubwürdigkeit das schafft man am
besten durch tun
deshalb hat das umweltministerium
letzten monate sein programm für die
kommunale klimaanpassung verlängert
wunsch durch die förderung von
klimaanpassung manager in sinnvoll
ergänzt klimaanpassung wird so zu einer
realistischen zu einem realistischen
aufgabenfeld für unsere städte und
gemeinden und das ist ein wichtiger
schritt
und entsandte koalition haben wir noch
einiges vor in den kommenden jahr dazu
gehört vor allem auch die beschleunigung
von planungs zu haben und der abbau der
richtlinien die nachhaltigkeit und
vielfalt in unseren innenstädten zurzeit
noch erschweren hier ist ein guter
interessensausgleich notwendig deshalb
müssen wir diese maßnahmen sorgsam
prüfen
aber es ist auch jetzt schon mit der
ampel werden unsere innenstädte
lebendiger wir stärken das nebeneinander
von bars geschäften clubs und cafés
beispielsweise durch die geplante
novelle des immissionsschutzgesetzes
in vielen kleineren städten bereitet der
leerstand in den innenstädten große
sorgen beim prüfen ob dem mit einer
erneuerung des vorkaufsrechts für
kommunen und einer engen verzahnung
zwischen bebauungsplänen und
flächennutzungsplänen und begegnet
werden kann
wir wollen resilient vielfältige und
lebendige innenstädte und in der
ampelkoalition bringen wir hierzu mit
dem neuen haushalt einiges mit dem weg
denn am ende können nur dort wo die
knurren genug finanziellen spielraum
haben innenstädte vorangebracht werden
es ist deshalb zentral dass die ampel
sich der verschlafenen aufgabe stellt
die kommunen endlich finanziell ihren
herausforderungen angemessen
auszustatten
hierbei sind schon einige schritte
unternommen worden es gibt zusagen für
die geflüchtete finanzierung die
verstetigung des höheren anteils an den
kosten der unterkunft das zügige und
entschlossene anfassen der altschulden
frage das sind alles wichtige schritte
es braucht aber noch
substanziell mehr geld für den
kommunalen klimaschutz eine
weiterführung des finanziellen
engagement des bundes für die
kinderbetreuung und eine deutliche
vereinfachung unseres fördersystems ich
freue mich darauf dass wir auch diese
punkte gemeinsam als ampel auf den weg
bringen werden
ihr antrag der union zeigt in jedem fall
er die versäumnisse der letzten jahre
auf als dass er uns wirklich
voranbringt die als ampel stellten jetzt
schon in diesem jahr mit diesem haushalt
sport der in jugendzentren freizeit und
kultureinrichtungen
senioren und begegnungsstätten
sollten konzepte einfallen erlauben sie
doch eine zwischenfrage des kollegen
lange
sollten in konzepte ein dann kommen sie
aber bitte zum schluss ihrer rede zeit
ist vorbei
die ampel regierung wird an vielen
schrauben drehen für eine stärkung der
kommunen und eine stadtentwicklung für
die innenstädte der zukunft das erwarten
unsere städte und gemeinden zu recht ich
freue mich darauf diese aufgaben
anzufassen
und zu einer kurzintervention anteilig
des voi lange
sehr geehrte frau kollegin ok
ich empfehle ihnen mal einen austausch
mit den kollegen daldrup von der spd mit
dem wir ja zwölf jahre zusammen regiert
haben die städtebauförderung diese
vorhin angesprochen haben insbesondere
die vereinfachung und die themen
stadtgrün haben wir in der letzten
periode zu neuen programmen
zusammengefasst flexibler gemacht das
was sie hier genannt haben finden sie
heute schon in den programmen
informieren sie sich mal bei ihren
kommunen in der kommunalpolitik welche
umsetzungsmöglichkeiten da gibt kann man
auch klimamanager davon mit bezahlen da
bereits vorgenommen werden wenn sie das
thema ansprechen
kultur jugend sport dann empfehle ich
ihnen darauf hinzuwirken in der
koalition das programm jugend sport
kultur wieder aufzulegen wenn ich den
haushalt richtig im kopf habe wird nur
aus finanziert und ist nicht mehr neu
enthalten dann setzen sie doch
tatsächlich wenn sie jetzt regieren das
um was sie uns hier als versäumnis
vorhalten wir haben es gemacht sie sind
drachen
jr sie können die antworten
vielen dank für den hinweis keine sorge
mit händedruck bin ich in gutem kontakt
genauso wie mit unseren städten und
gemeinden und landkreisen ich komme
selber aus der kommunalpolitik selber
aus der kommunalen verwaltung ich glaube
der informationsfluss steht dankeschön
klaus peter willsch ist der nächste
redner der in der debatte von der
fraktionen cdu/csu
dankeschön auch präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren die im
kollegen mit
kollege lange hat ja gerade mal richtig
gestellt frau otte was da an ihren
äußerungen
korrekt korrektur würde ich war und ich
sag mal darüber hinaus auch im mit auf
den außen darauf eingehen wie sie mit
diesem ein bisschen auto bashing und ein
bisschen mehr wohlfühlen das ist ja
nicht getan wir müssen wirklich vor ort
lösungen finden die passend zu den
leuten und dann ist es wichtig dass man
auch plätze erreichen kann ich habe
gerade heute wieder telefoniert man
einer frau die ich gesagt morgen habe
ich wieder dreiviertelstunde vor dieser
fahrt einer ampel gestanden und nach in
die stadt rein zu kommen weil dann grün
der verkehrsdezernent ihre vorstellungen
durchsetzen will die däninnen im
innenstadthandel nachhaltig schaden
ich meine auch wenn die letzten dann
sich nun aufmachen trotz inflation und
wer trotz und nach pandemie überwindung
und in einer situation wo man vielleicht
beim wetter her wie der luftkrieg
einkaufen zu gehen dann sagen sie bitte
auf ihre militanten außen gruppen davon
der letzten generation abidi heißen dass
es sich nicht mehr festlegen sollen auf
den straßen damit die leute wenigstens
hinkommen zu den leben und nicht
abgehalten werden von denen die da
meinen sie alle erzählen in ihrem sinne
ich werde ganz zu begeben noch ein habig
erlauben sie eine zwischenfrage aus der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
herr kollege will ich fordere sie auf
dass sie richtig stellen dass die
gruppen die sich der angesprochen haben
die straßen blockieren keine militanten
außen gruppen von bündnis 90 die grünen
sind und dass sie an dieser stelle zur
wahrheit zurückkommen vielen dank
dass
dann ist das vielleicht eine
fehlwahrnehmung von mir gewesen aber ich
habe noch nicht viele kräftige
aussagen gehört die sich distanziert
hätten von diesem freiheits
beschränkenden und und
rechtsstaatswidrig verhalten was wir da
jeder trainer flughafen tufan amstätter
eingehen und was weiß ich wo überall
machen sie es machen sie es deutlich sie
haben hier jetzt schon mal beitrag dazu
geleistet lassen der bundesvorstand der
fraktion beschließen er heftige
distanzierung davon und aufruf dieser
drucken da endlich wieder auf
rechtsstaatlichem boden zurückzukommen
und dann bin ich bereit gehende alle
hände zu reichen die mir zur verfügung
stehen
ich will um auch um auch erst einmal im
bett menschlich ist signal zu senden wir
haben gerade gehört dass der kollege
habe heute den minister nicht dabei sein
kann weil er positiv getestet ist zu
hoffen dass ein symptomfreien verlauf
hat denn so läuft wie bei mir ich habe
es kurz vor weihnachten dann ist es gut
das wünschen wir ihm auch unternehmen
das auch natürlich entsprechend positiv
zur kenntnis dass sie uns hier
informieren darüber ich will
noch einmal ganz kurz weil fachlich also
sowohl das menschliche der persönlichen
betroffenheit dass carsten linnemann
geschildert hat geschildert hat als auch
dass das städtebauliche
entwicklungspolitischer was ulrich
langer noch mal sehr deutlich
klargestellt hat
nochmal an 1 appellieren versuchen sie
doch mal wirklich das leben mit
deutschland so zu nehmen wie es ist
in deutschland leben fast 60 prozent in
einheiten unter 50.000 mein wahlkreis
rheingau taunus limburg der ist
deutschland so ist deutschland größter
stadt 36.000 einwohner und da sind schon
die stadtteile mitgezählt und dann ist
das 180 da verteilt und da können sie
nicht mit ihren one fits all lösung auto
bashing und was weiß ich was kommen wenn
sie den lebenswirklichkeit der menschen
gerecht werden wollen dann müssen sie
ein bisschen mehr bieten und müssen ein
bisschen mehr sich den menschen zuwenden
in ihrer konkreten lebenssituation ich
muss leider
ich komme dann aber dazu den positiven
abbinden auch auf die kollegin matschig
nummer 1 gehen das hat nämlich gezeigt
worauf wir in dieser großen koalition
immer rücksicht mussten sobald das thema
ladenöffnungszeiten überhaupt nur
angedacht wird kommt schon diese von
gewerkschaften infizierte gegenreaktion
gottes welt abbau von
arbeitnehmerrechten
das ist auch nicht die
lebenswirklichkeit reden sie doch mal
mit menschen die den einzelhandel aber
wir haben keine probleme sondern das zu
besetzen wenn sie soll das maul
aufmachen können weil die leute gerne
arbeiten die da der teilzeit wieder
teilzeit oder geringfügig beschäftigt
sind aber das wollen sie das wollen sie
nicht zur kenntnis nehmen sie wollen
sich nicht stören lassen in ihrem
ideologischen gerüst durch aspekte aus
der lebenswirklichkeit
ich hab' ich hab' ich habe
wahrgenommen das hat todenhausen sich
nochmal an dem nicht nur formal
verkündeten freedom day abgearbeitet hat
in seiner argumentation aber ich musste
1 zusammenfassend feststellen ich habe
selten erlebt er seinen antrag so viel
übereinstimmung im ganzen haus gefunden
hat von allen seiten ist er gelobt
worden die einnahmen gesagt copy on pace
die anderen haben gesagt hätten wir
alles schon gemacht werden wir gekonnt
hätten die können jetzt also ich habe
große hoffnung dass wir ein großer in
großem einvernehmen hier diesen antrag
der cdu csu annehmen denn nach all dem
was jetzt schon positiv dazu gesagt
worden ist kann ich mir gar nichts
anderes mehr vorstellen
ich lade sie dazu herzlich ein das
diskutieren denn unsere innenstädte sind
es wert wir haben doch eine wende an
denkmalschutz denken was macht das für
einen sinn wenn da niemand mehr hingeht
weil sie nicht belohnt da hinzugehen es
müssen erlebnisräume seien die
innenstädte die ortskerne und dann muss
man auch den kommunen die luft lassen
das zu entscheiden vor ort wie sie es
für richtig halten sie wollen bürokratie
entlasten gehen sie es dann schaffen sie
diese unseligen stundenzettel ab die die
leute abends ausfüllen haben sie bitte
zum schönsten wild stehen sie überlegen
sie mal an ich bin der genehmigungs
funktion arbeiten kann bei umbauten bei
genehmigungspflichtigen
angelegenheiten für den einzelhandel
denn
lankl und danke der präsident noch mal
ganz herzlich für ihre geduld
helfen sie mit helfen sie mit dass wir
die innenstädte lebendig halten und das
wären ja zehn jahre
lang das wird denen unterstützung jetzt
zuteil werden sie wieder aufbauen können
klaus peter willsch war das aus der
unionsfraktion hier mit seiner rede wie
die innenstädte der einzelhandel in den
innenstädten attraktiv gestaltet werden
kann und unterstützt werden kann auf ihn
antworten wird es johannes alt von davis
titel
wie soll die gemeinde der zukunft
aussehen und lieber herr wild ich habe
700 davon am wahlkreises auch der
ländliche raum ist das zeichen wichtiger
aspekt da stimme ich ihnen zu nachdem
wir heute bereits über viele
detailfragen geredet haben und
vorschläge aus ihrem antrag dann ist es
doch jetzt wo sich zum ende der bass
normalen struck zurücktreten möchte und
ein paar grundsätzliche erwägungen in
den blick nehmen möchte stellen sie sich
vor wir müssen die städte die
grundzentren die mittelzentren die
oberseite neu planen neu denken wie
würden wir das heute machen da kann die
lösung jetzt auch nicht sein dass wir
nur an den symptomen ansätzen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der union
viele dinge sind richtig die sie dort in
ihrem antrag haben aber es doch zu sehr
von dem geist des konservieren zustrom
hier ein schräubchen daran schräubchen
ich glaube wir müssen da ein bisschen
größer denken und wenn wir an die
innenstädte denken die funktions
getrennte innenstadt die allein dem
einzelhandel dient ist eine entwicklung
der nachkriegszeit gucken wir uns die
stadtentwicklung 1900 dann sehen wir
dort viertel nicht gelebt gearbeitet und
konsumiert wurde und diese funktion
mischung sollte uns orientierung seien
innovative modelle müssen hierher
wie sollte also die stadt der zukunft
aussehen während der pandemie so zeigen
es befragung standen für über 60 prozent
der innenstadtbesucher begegnungen im
vordergrund gefolgt von dem wunsch den
einzelhandel zu unterstützen und café
und restaurant besuchen wir wissen also
was für menschen innenstädte attraktiv
macht vielfalt da sollten sie sich
vielfältiger aufstellen mit wohnen leben
arbeiten gastronomie das ensemble und
mit kurzen wegen und dies nicht allein
im stadtzentrum
letzte woche hat euch auf einer
berichterstatter reise nach schweden und
dänemark die gelegenheit zu sehen wie
einer alten industriestadt landskroner
mit konsequenter stadtentwicklung ein
neuanfang gewagt wurde vor sozial
problematische viertel wenn durch
verlegung von verkehrswegen von einer
randlage in die mitte der stadt gerückt
neue attraktive townhouses werden
zwischen vormalige sozialwohnungen
gebaut und mit schulen und
einkaufsmöglichkeiten ergänzt um soziale
segregation abzubauen und neue steuer
kräftige bürger in die stadt zu locken
dies braucht auch vor allen dingen mut
mut ebenen übergreifend
zusammenzuarbeiten und ganzheitliche
entscheidung für eine gemeinde zu
treffen
fragen wir nach der zukunft der stadt
und der gemeinde sollten wir keineswegs
den ländlichen raum vergessen das
dorfzentrum der zukunft ist genauso
richtigen das könnte ein gebäude sein
dass die unterschiedlichsten funktionen
unter einem dach versammelt vom netz
nehmen der coworking spaces neben der
möglichkeit zur arbeiten sind dass orte
der begegnung orte der kultur und orte
der bildung
seiner letzten rede habe ich ihnen von
den dörfern immer im wahlkreis berichtet
wo man oft auf den apfelbaum steigen
muss um netzempfang zu haben dort ist
die einzige vorhandene öffentliche
infrastruktur oft die bushaltestelle und
der briefkasten an der kein bus fährt
übrigens der bushaltestelle und jetzt
kommt uns gerade eine junge gründe denn
aus einem dorf bei waren zu die gerade
gestern mit ganz ganz viele eigenem
engagement ihren co working space weg
gegründet hat um ihrem dorf eine mitte
zurückzugeben ein coworking mit
besprechungs flächen im aufnahmestudio
für videos und für ton für unternehmen
und auch einen dorfladen mit einem café
mit einem 24 stunden zugang elektronisch
vollkommen innovativ hier könnten auch
noch andere dienstleistungen wie post
und einzelhändler andocken also es geht
nicht nur um fördermittel allein sondern
innovations- und gründergeist für unsere
dörfer und ich danke heute katharina
scheunemann für alle die hier fuhren
alle alle die eine initiative haben ihr
land leben zu bereichern für diesen
steinigen weg den sie geht um ihre
heimat neu aufzustellen
die ampel koalition hat bereits einige
weichen gestellt dort büros und co
working spaces werden als teil der
daseinsvorsorge
anerkannt und zusätzlich gefördert ein
programm für den küstenschutz und ja die
erleben aktuell eine schwere krise der
innenstädte und ortskerne doch gibt es
diese krise zugleich auch die
möglichkeit die stadt der zukunft zu
denken dieser fordert mut mut vor ort
durch konsequente anwendung des
planungsrechts sowie eine
unbürokratische zusammenarbeit wir
sollten darüber nachdenken die über
komplexe förderlandschaft zu
vereinfachen programme zusammenzuführen
zu digitalisieren und somit auch für
kleine städte und gemeinden den aufwand
der beantragen zu begrenzen dies könnte
unser beitrag seien die städte und
gemeinden zur zukunft zu befähigen ich
freue mich auf die beratung ihres
antrags im wirtschaftsausschuss vielen
dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
johannes alt aus der spd hat ist eben
angedeutet dieser antrag wird nach
dieser debatte an die entsprechenden
ausschüsse überwiesen und der
wirtschaftsausschuss vista federführend
vorher gibt es aber noch einen redner
und das ist tagen reinhold von den
liberalen
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen also auch ich danke der union
für den vorgelegten antrag und ich danke
ihr noch wegen einer anderen sache
nämlich dass sie ganz selbstständig ihre
versäumnisse der letzten jahre auf
arbeitet das entlastet uns als herzige
regierung von dieser aufgabe mir wäre es
zu viele seelen striptease er ich würde
hier mit hochrotem kopf und mit schweiß
auf der stirn stehen sie haben versierte
redner geschickt denen das nicht
passiert ist dass es gut deshalb liest
sich dieser antrag im übrigen auch wie
abgeschrieben aus dem koalitionsvertrag
war da stehen ja die versäumnisse ihrer
regierungszeit drin und das was dieses
land jetzt braucht deshalb ist es sich
nämlich so schade schade dass das
umdenken was eben dem antrag geschrieben
haben jetzt erst kommt ganz ehrlich
dieses umdenken das hätte nicht schon
vor sechs monaten sondern vor jahren
passieren müssen bei dem internet wo ich
mich immer ein weder gibt es den online
handel seit vielen vielen jahren hätte
ihnen auch vorher einfahren können jetzt
herlinde waren sie sagen keiner
verantwortung wegschieben die cdu
landesminister wenn vorbildlicher weise
stadtrat ladenöffnungszeiten geschrieben
in dem antrag entdecken sie ja ihre
freude zur liberalisierung der
ladenöffnungszeiten selbst sonntags und
peter regin angesprochen ich komme aus
dem tourismusland mich kurzer zeit
jahrzehnten an dass wir die leute zum
geburtstag einladen und sonst keine
torte hinstellen er ich habe dann
probleme da jetzt mal zu ihrer
verantwortung denn nicht nur zu recht
die gewerkschaften sind fürs personal
machen sie sich stark in meinem
bundesland ist es immer wieder die union
die sagt der kirche hat muss am sonntag
möglich sein story aus bayern ich glaube
in bayern regieren sie da gibt es ein
geiles modell das nennt sich josefs
nahkauf box total geiles ding
digitalisierung zusammengebracht
arbeitskräftemangel verhindert laden der
ohne personal funktioniert der darf in
ihrem regierten bayern sonntags nicht
öffnen einnahmen ohne personal verboten
in bayern das ist also das wahre wesen
der union
ich darf
auch wenn es wäre auf der seele brennt
nichts weiter über den walk down und den
erkenntnissen die sie gewonnen haben die
haben sie jetzt wieder geschrieben aber
eine sache die muss ich erwähnen war das
schlägt dem fass den boden aus und zwar
gehörig
kommt 13 dieses antrages greift einen
antrag auf einen entschließungsantrag
der letzten legislatur diesen hohen
hauses da geht es um die änderung der
baunutzungsverordnung eine neue idee der
durchmischung der stadt neues
zusammenleben der stadt da kämpfen
parlamentarier über alle bänke hinweg
jahre lang an einem thema wofür ihre
minister horst seehofer tut seehofer aus
dem kabinett aus dem alten sitzen ja
noch hier die offene ohren haben immer
wieder hat das ministerium ins
abgeblockt alle parlamentarier fast alle
fast alle parlament beschließen einen
entschließungsantrag dass die regierung
aufgefordert wird noch in der letzten
legislatur die baunutzungsverordnung zu
ändern seehofer macht alles nur durch
das was das parlament will und jetzt
haben sie die frechheit sich
hinzustellen und zu sagen diese
baunutzungsverordnung solle jetzt sofort
umgesetzt werden natürlich steht das im
koalitionsvertrag war es ein richtiger
schritt ist und wir werden das als ampel
auch machen aber so 30 aufzutreten dass
ich ihnen nicht durchgehen
nachdem seelen striptease
nachdem seelen striptease kommt ja noch
was anderes das wesen der union
verändert sich grad das müssen wir auch
mal deutlich sagen für alle die
kommunalpolitik machen sonst war die
union ja in einer partei die auch die
kommunale selbstverwaltung hoch gehalten
hat sind wir auch und jetzt lese ich in
diesem antrag dass wir also mit ge und
verboten in den kommunen stark agieren
sollen am besten aus dem bundestag und
zwar mit gebührenfreien parkplätzen also
ich hab nichts gegen gebührenfreie
parkplätze aber wenn wir jetzt anfangen
für jede kommune deutschlands im
bundestag über gebührenfreie parkplätze
dazu diskutieren der hat den aufbau
unserer republik noch nicht verstanden
und nicht verstanden dass wir gute
kommunalpolitiker haben sie das für
tiere statt in jedem einzelfall bestens
allein erscheinen können ich freue mich
ich freue mich selbsterkenntnis ist der
erste schritt zur besserung hat mein
vater mir gesagt habe recht gehabt diese
selbsterkenntnis haben sie als gewonnen
dazu gratuliere ich ihnen herzlich
deshalb wird wahrscheinlich die
zusammenarbeit was dieses thema betrifft
in dieser legislatur ganz wunderbar
funktionieren und alle koalitions
anträge den nächsten monaten werden sie
konzipieren beschloss ich komme zum
schluss bedanke mich für die möglichkeit
dieser tollen rede wünschen uns einen
schönen nachgedacht
hagen reinhold bedankt sich für die
möglichkeit dieser tollen rede das ist
auf ein schönes schlusssatz für diese
debatte zu den impulsen für einzelhandel
und innenstädte auf antrag der cdu csu
fraktion